[Music]
Isaac hel thank you so much for joining
me from Jerusalem to Startup Nation
United um calling um and sharing our
experiences as the startup nation is
coming together United efforts um
obviously past three weeks where we're
on October 29th now so just about three
weeks uh and a day after the the and two
days after terrible um terrible
incidents of October 7th which triggered
uh the war as well um as the CEO of a
startup as part of the startup Nation
I'm I'm really thankful to have you here
both to provide me with some insights
and inspiration as to the things you've
experienced with your own employees and
your own people that the way that you've
experienced yourself H the you know your
own efforts as well as some higher level
ideas of what's happening so again thank
you very much for being here
Isaac yeah good to see you my Micha
wonderful tell me a little bit first of
all about yourself and about trulan and
what are you doing the daytoday outside
the context of the war that we're in
yeah definitely so I'm CEO co-founder of
trulan trulan is AI powered accounting
technology uh we have I would say about
70 employees to date more than 50 in
Israel in our Tel Aviv office and the
rest in New York in in the US um and you
can imagine I have a few day jobs as he
but I would say that what's unique about
me especially during this time is I made
Aliyah so I immigrated um from America
I'm Texan to Israel and I'm so I'm
unique in the sense that I guess you
could say I'm an Israeli American
founder uh during this time inde
wonderful well it's it's really great uh
it's really great to have you here um
and um obviously um the October 7th
events caught all of us off guard tell
me a little bit about where were you in
know what happened you know for you that
morning and then I'd love to hear a
little bit about it what what what H
what transpired with your organization
and your employees in the days following
the terrible
incidents yeah definitely so um I live
in Jerusalem our office is in Tel Aviv
um I'm Sabbath observance so on that
Saturday the the tragic day we were
celebrating Sim T and Shabbat a very
happy day uh for families and mainly for
kids uh to celebrate get candy
unfortunately before we could get to the
local synagogue uh the the sirens
started ringing um this was about 8:15
in the morning in Jerusalem and happened
throughout the day so we were back and
forth in the stairwell in the bomb
shelter during that day H because we
don't turn on our phones on Sabbath uh
we did not know the extent of what
happened we obviously heard rumors there
were some people immediately got called
to the Army through their microphones or
or other communication devices but it
wasn't until the Sabbath and holiday
ended you know close to 7 8 p.m. that we
turn on our phones and understood the
extent of everything so you know it's
Sundown it's it's nighttime and the
first thing you do is is make sure your
family is safe right I'm uh uh I have a
family father of three my wife make sure
everything's okay make sure that our
family back home in America in Texas
knows that we're safe um your extended
family in Israel your family and friends
and then you immediately stap into your
responsibilities as a CEO of a company
and you start to make sure that your
employees your your brothers and sisters
in your company um are doing okay and
that's where it all
starts wow and so the days following the
incident immediately your your employees
sprung into action and I know a few of
them myself and a few of the amazing
initiatives that that they've done in
fact some of them may be as part of this
miniseries on on their own initiatives
and tell me give me you know a little
bit of an observation from you what were
some of these initiatives that your
employees took place how how did you
experience it as a CEO and as a larger
part of the startup Nation seeing know
everybody sort of jump in and contribute
yet yeah first of all I mean it was it
was overwhelming obviously the first few
days everyone was in shock um and
immediately people moved to action so I
can give you a few examples um of
that inspired me again everyone in our
company doing amazing things um Ariel in
our company who's a local Rabbi to
families who are dealing with it whose
parents got drafted to the Army dealing
with the kids the wives helping counsel
them um Linda from our customer success
team who has a Spanish background
helping charter a flight from Madrid for
medical supplies actually president
herzo called her and the team to
congratulate them they were they were
amazed at it was happening uh Mikey in
in finance um seeking to raise uh a
million dollars for protective vests for
the IDF not just that but the unit that
he served in and also um you know a
trainer who's been helping our company
is serving in right now so we got to
deliver it to you know our friends uh
three people from midle were immediately
called up uh from the engineering side
so thinking about them G in HR her her
mother was rescuing animals uh in those
first few days uh you've all shinb I
could keep going on I mean these these
stories were extremely expiring for the
money the medical supplies and just the
AK the the responsibility and
togetherness of
everyone and how so how does an
organization as a company obviously you
have to um you know you have to you have
customers to serve your global company
customers abroad as well how did how did
you work and out as a as a c and as a
leader sort of this balance between okay
there's a war going on our employees are
also hyper engaged which is phenomenal
that's part of the unity and the part of
the story of the startup Nation how do
you now as a leader balance that and and
how did you personally experience that
yeah well it's a good question I mean
first of all you you you remind yourself
that a startup is a family and so a lot
of things that happen are are natural
they're they're the they're the actions
that would happen when you are together
with a family um I also think that uh
you know it's easy that's that's what
I'll say it's easy because it's humid
it's very humid to care about each other
and think about each other and you also
realize as CEO you know we forget why we
do this right we forget why we're an
engineer an accountant or you know a
salesperson but uh we do it for our our
family we do it for our values we do it
to make a few shekels we do it to have
you know a little money for coffee
entertainment our place all those things
like this is our life right and it
starts with our family and our friends
and our country and you know you you
can't get to the work without first
starting with the life so all of this
comes from people get their energy for
truan and for work from their life and
from their missions in life that go
beyond work and uh for me it was very
very easy uh all all that happened was
we were reminded of our core values and
our mission and what we're really
fighting for and from there uh we just
started moving now today it's three
weeks in um we have investors we have
hundreds and hundreds of customers
around the globe we have had to make
sure that there's business continuity so
then you get into the statistics okay
well we have you know five people out of
50 on miluim that's 10% that can be a
productivity loss okay we have people
who are in Israel who can't respond to
support tickets well we have a New York
team so they're helping out and you
start rebound balancing the company a
little bit you realize that the people
in New York are so motivated to help the
people in Israel right the engineers
whose friends are miluim are so
motivated to step in um and you assess
the impact and you know fortunately our
investors invested in our company and
invested in Israel because of our
resilience and because of our growth so
they've been nothing but uh supportive
and um that's it we're we've we've grown
a very very strong muscle that didn't
exist
before I I love it how what what you
also had a pretty significant action
within this within this word yourself so
not not only you have a a family to
manage and the company to manage but
you've also taken actions yourself um to
to to be part of this effort where were
some of the things that you personally
did in response to the October 7th
events yeah again it's it's it just
comes natural I mean I uh I was involved
with some friends who are organizing
Refugee placement from families in the
south
stot these kind of places um so I got
involved in finding houses in in
Jerusalem and other areas where they
could potentially stay and that was one
thing I did yeah and we we had some
tough decisions so the week a week after
the massacre you know I had a trip to
New York right scheduled for work with
interviews and partner meetings and
stuff like that and right when it broke
out I wasn't planning on going but
immediately I was told by you know my
mentors and my investors and really my
colleagues and and my co-founder that
you know as a nons soldier you know we
we need to fight too right and so I went
on that trip I took my family which was
a difficult thing to get on a plane and
then you know come back um but we opened
our home to a refugee family from
netivot and that that meant a lot to me
just being able to help in some way and
now we're we're back in Israel so it
it's uh it's it's all good and we're
still
fighting love it and and so so look at a
little bit higher you know higher level
you know we're 3 weeks at now it's
October 29th what what is the experience
now so know how do you describe the the
current situation how do you describe
you know the way that you're perceiving
it and and what what are the big the the
big building blocks that that you see
occurring especially as it pertains to
Startup Nation the convicts and all of
this yeah definitely well I I try to
break it down you know in uh in in
Jewish religion you have Shiva which is
the first seven days which were a period
of deep deep mourning for the massacre
you have schim which are the next 30
days which is a period not of as much
mourning but of some level of mourning
and I think we're in that period we're
still very much mourning and thinking
about everything that happened there and
so there's just some days it's hard uh
to push through um but you have to right
we're getting into the the year of Shiva
and now we're fighting a war which is a
whole new layer it's obviously connected
but it's a very very heavy time so um we
need to
convert that sadness into what are we
going to do for our country for our
hostages really for Humanity right it's
not just Israel it's America it's Europe
it's other countries and people that are
fighting for a certain type of value
set um and Michael like I I get
inspiration from um my predecessors
right I was just in New York last week
speaking on a they asked to speak on a
panel you everyone wants to talk to
Israeli entrepreneurs now and the panel
was called AI in Israel and they said
you know what what's going to happen now
with the Israeli economy what's going to
happen with Israeli companies and I said
look in 2001 you had the second inata
which I remember well my as an American
my Israel trip got canceled there were
bus bombings in Tel Aviv and hia in
Jerusalem at a pizzeria a sparrow
Pizzeria Jerusalem I said that was 2001
right we're at an AI conference some of
the biggest companies in the world are
Mobi AI for autonomous driving you know
melanox AI for chips right these
companies were founded in you know 98 99
2000 right these companies were were a
few years old when they were going
through the second inat and they were
going through these experiences and look
at these companies right now right look
at how much they represent to the world
to Israel to Innovation to all these
areas um and so for me like you talk
about business continuity I am so like
inspired just to see that again you
can't go in and compare tragedies that's
not fair right this was a massacre of
really really traumatic proportion but
just to see that so many people before
us have experienced adversity and come
out stronger and and promoted their
values till the last you know breath is
what's what's making me realize that we
need to keep going we need to go strong
100% And I have no doubt that this well
will come out strong and uh as as we've
been doing over the last 7even years
with every occurrence we come out
stronger than before and obviously as
the startup nation and nation that you
know that's leading in a lot of in a lot
of vertical around the world to
technology but particularly also in Ai
and cyber I think that's were obviously
um continue going to continue leading it
and uh we what I've also been
experiencing
myself from the Cyber site how we've
been coming together as a nation
leveraging deep technology and
leveraging really phenomenal technology
to to work on the hostage situation and
and different um different technological
tools that before have never been used
really in in the context of warn battles
and and it's been inspiring for me to
see how companies around Israel have
been coming together providing not only
their people but also technology to to
make a positive impact and realize like
thank you so much for joining me and
very difficult time for all of us but
we'll have a better days and we'll all
push forward and thank you very much for
the
inspiration absolutely thanks Michael
keep it
[Laughter]
up